So far, we've been dealing with quadratic polynomials, like x squared plus 5 x
plus 6, to figure out how to factor this. We've been looking for two numbers
that add to equal the middle term coefficient, and multiply to equal the final
coefficient. So, in the case of this polynomial, we end up with 2 and 3 as our
two coefficients. What if I told you, though, that this quantity a,b, in other
words, the product of the two numbers that add to equal the middle coefficient,
is also equal to the product of two coefficients from the original expression.
Let's just play around with this for a second, though. I'm going to name each of
the coefficients of each term in this three term expression A, B, and C. So, A
in this case is 1, B is 5, and C is 6. So before we found the two numbers that
add to equal this term, they were 2 and 3. But what if I told you that these
multiply to equal not just this final term, but actually the product of two of
the coefficients in this expression over here. So the two numbers we found to
equal this coefficient B, multiply to equal what? Do they multiply to equal A
squared, B squared, C squared, AB, BC, or AC?